can you find the seal on the ball
it's hiding behind those blocks
what about the rubber band
that's over by the alligator
does this look familiar
these photos are from the i spy book
series introduced in 1992 and there's a
good chance that either you or your kids
have read them but did you know that all
of these images were created with real
objects the magic and mystery within
these books is directly tied to the
imagination of the photographer behind
them walter wick
my name is walter wick i am a photo
illustrator and i've been doing that for
i don't know how long since 1991. before
i spy walter was a commercial
photographer in new york city one of his
clients was games magazine which created
puzzles and activities for each issue
but how did walter end up working on i
spy one day around 1980 walter was
cleaning up his studio and he decided to
take a picture of the stray nuts and
bolts he had lying around walter used
that photo to promote his work which is
how the author jean marzolo saw it
i got a call from g marzolo to do a
poster for
her magazine which is called let's find
out it's a kindergarten magazine an
editor at scholastic books saw that
poster and asked if gene and walter
wanted to make a search and find
children's book gene would write the
rhymes and walter would create the
images and i said sure and that's how it
started
but perhaps what made the book so
successful was how realistic they looked
the combination of props sets and
lighting created an immersive scene
originally walter used a large format
camera to photograph each scene this
created huge 8x10 negatives which was
ideal because the larger image size
captured a ton of detail
then around 2004 walter switched to
digital he now uses a canon 5d but
walter was quick to point out that the
camera does little of the real work
because it just sits there while walter
spends weeks building the sets walter's
studio is filled with the props and
materials he uses to build these
incredible images like blocks buttons
toys and even pine cones
i would hide the objects as i would
build the shot i wouldn't really think
about building the hiding the objects
first i would create the shot make a
list of the hidden objects send it to
jean and then she would write the rhyme
each scene is arranged very carefully
around a central idea or theme like
nature antiques or school
one of the problems with photo
illustrations is you're limited by
what you have available the higher level
concepts became harder and harder and
harder to do though as i went on because
i didn't want to repeat myself
but i spy isn't the only series walter
has worked on he's also the author and
photo illustrator of the can you see
what i see books and hey seymour which
follow the search and find style of i
spy in order to make these scenes a
reality walter works with assistants
fabricators and model makers for can you
see what i see toyland express walter's
team built a toy train from scratch
because they needed to show it being
assembled throughout the story each
photo can take anywhere from a couple
days to several weeks to create the
attention to detail is part of what
makes these photos so compelling and
walter continues to capture the
imagination of readers today his newest
book array of light is a science book
that uses beautiful photos to illustrate
the properties of light it's a companion
to walter's 1997 book a drop of water
i've always wanted to do the book online
i was a little afraid of it because as
much as i work with light and i
know light i was a little afraid to
trying to explain the inner workings of
it to young readers
but i finally did that
the i spy and can you see what ic books
have over 45 million copies in print the
care and attention to detail put into
every frame still resonates with readers
today i was very surprised right from
the very beginning
how intensely kids
looked at my photographs
so i just put this same intensity back
into making it
imagination and the sense of discovery
are timeless
[Music]